great collaborators you see here and
most of the heavy lifting was done by
Eliot grad student working with papers
just presented yes you'll meet ICML
meeting a couple weeks ago so we're
gonna start off with the idea of fair
representation learning I know a lot of
people are familiar with so I'll go to
say briefly the idea would be that we
start off with some there's no a little
pointer is there there's we have some
input let's imagine we have some feature
dimensions of a vector X and also some
sensitive attribute a that's the inputs
of the system and we learn to rip a
representation function f that comes up
with a representation Z for each example
right so for every X a combination
there's a different Z and then that Z
vector can be used for multiple tasks so
that's one of the aims and fair
representation learning is transfer you
can take the same representation and use
it for different tasks so that's being
shown here by G 1 G 2 G 3 these could be
different classification tasks that use
the same representation so the aims are
given some sensitive attribute a that
we'll just think of as a simp for now
like we talked about the last talk for
simplicity let's have a binary we want
the Z that Z that's the new
representation to satisfy a fairness
constraint and that fairness constraint
could be something like demographic pari
or many of the other constraints like
equalized odds or other things and we
want so Z is independent of a in the
case of demographic parity and it
maintains as much information about X as
possible it's a goal of this is that the
reason why we do this is that if you
think of what the purpose of the fair
representation is it acts as a kind of
parody bottleneck for the group so it
makes group disparities downstream less
okay so the idea is that if Z is
independent
a then any y-hat I so Y hat is a
prediction about some variable Y so Y
hat I is gonna be G I of Z so that's
task I is also going to be independent
of a for all I okay so let's go up with
a good fair representation that's fair
at the level of Z
okay it's my machine or the okay an
earthquake and in general current
approaches are flexible with respect to
downstream labels but they aren't
flexible with respect to sensitive
attributes so that's what this work is
about is trying to extend beyond having
single binary attributes and the
motivation for that is many people know
is that you can ml systems discriminate
against subgroups based on conjunctions
of the sensitive attributes so we want
to think about a being a vector of
sensitive attributes there's lots of
work currently in the field on that
including by many of the people here in
the room some great work on both this
the multi accuracy multi calibration
fairness gerrymandering where this
definition of what is a sensitive
attribute isn't just expanded to be a
vector but it's something that's
computationally defined so it can be
kind of anything that's just can be
computed using some well-defined
structure from the data okay very
interesting and relevant work there's
also some work on compositional fair
representations coming up with groups of
sense of attributes through compositions
and a kind of graph setup so here's the
motivation for what we're doing here
though is in a targeted advertising so a
common kind of motivation and we have
the same set of individuals are
participating in multiple ad campaigns
okay
maybe they willingly or unwillingly
they're participating in a whole bunch
of ad campaigns and the different
products are advertisers they have
different tasks they've different you
know they want to predict as this person
relevant for this particular ad campaign
another ad campaign you know is this
person relevant all right and we don't
even know what all the system I don't
even know what are all the different ad
campaigns you might want to compute for
this in the set of individuals right so
this is the multiple tasks idea and the
transfer learning idea but we're
extending that to think of it where each
task might have its own set of ant
sensitive attributes okay so we could
have it that for one ad campaign were
the
concern is discriminating against black
females another ad campaign could be I
don't know for insurance you know I
won't discriminate against teenage males
okay so it could be a different set of
sensitive attributes for each task so
that's where the flexibly fare comes in
well our goal is to come up with a
single encoder a single mapping F that
takes XNA and produces a Z that can be
adapted to the sensitive attributes that
are specific to the application so how
could you do that well you can imagine
what you would do that is have a
different one way to do is just train up
a whole separate system for each
application right but now we want to do
this transfer so another way to do they
have different encoders with different
sets of sense of attributes okay so each
encoder is specific to a set of
sensitive attributes that also doesn't
scale very well it's not very efficient
so we want to have a single common
encoder then this sense can be modulated
to say okay now for this particular case
we want to be sensitive to this subset
of sensitive attributes for this other
one that's this other subset okay won't
have this kind of flexibility so it
might a picture will help I think the
next to the next slide
oh sorry it's not the next light can you
hold on one more slide building up some
suspense so so we're to get there before
I describe exactly what we're gonna get
how we're gonna get there so that's more
about how we're gonna get there but at
least I said what the goal was okay the
goal is to be able to specify different
sense of attributes and use the same
encoder so we think this is related to
what's called disentangled
representation learning what that means
is that you're learning a representation
z a kind of embedding or a latent
representation for an input that's what
Z is and the goal and disentanglement is
that each dimension of Z should
correspond to a single semantic factor
of variation in the input it could be
object shape or object position or
various things okay
so it's this identification of
dimensions in the latent description or
in the
bedding with particular factors of
variation in the input disentangling
these factors of variation this is a
super hot area and machine learning
these days there was a ad ICML the best
paper winner was a an empirical paper on
this topic which basically benchmarked
current methods and showed they were all
pretty brittle right so that's a common
finding they're brittle in the sense
that you have to build in it turns out
to get them to work well this kind of
disentanglement yet the system has to
have some inductive biases built into it
either in the architecture of the system
or in the hyper parameters or various
other things like mean-field assumptions
various things that come into it that
encode information in a sense about the
inputs because it's a very hard problem
to do this in an unsupervised way just
say well we're hoping that this part of
the code is going to be shaped we're
hoping this part of the code is going to
be colored it's a very challenging
problem so they showed that you had to
do this in by building in some biases
and there are also a strong independence
assumptions about the factors of
variation the assumption is that each of
these things are varying independently
and one of the popular methods is this
variational auto encoder I'm not going
to go into the details of that here but
that's one common way of doing this kind
of unsupervised learning and the ones
that are useful for this entanglement
encourage to kind of factorize posterior
so that the Z is factorized into each
dimension has its own distribution then
the Joint Distribution is just the
product of the independence and this
works these tend to work well on
synthetic cases but when you get through
more realistic cases even simple
realistic cases like faces it turns out
that these methods don't work that well
so these are the two two of the most
popular methods for this entanglement
beta V AE and factor VA variants of
variational auto-encoders and what you
see here all know if you can see from
where you're sitting but they don't do a
great job of disentanglement so the
typical thing in this entanglement is
you take some that particular identified
latent dimension that corresponds to
let's say hair
color okay and you very that dimension
of Z and then you look at you generate
using a generative model or a decoder
from that and generate the input that
corresponds to everything else held the
same but that particular variable
changing okay so here colors traversed
from one end of the spectrum of its
value to the other it's a continuous
thing and you get hair that goes from
darker to later okay if you don't you
can see from where you're sitting but
lots of other things are changing about
the image it's not really just the hair
color and things like skin tone for
example lots of things are changing
that's not just about skin tone so it
doesn't do a great job these days or
hair lengths you don't really get a very
good variation in hair lengths here okay
so it doesn't work that well currently
these methods but the idea is good okay
ideas
so these are all very interpretive
features but maybe there is a
contradiction between being interpreter
features and being independent of each
other maybe the way to break things into
to integrate into independent features
will result in that's right so one of
the motivations I didn't really say one
of the motivations for disentanglement
is interpretability right so you want
each dimension to be interpretive what
it's also meant to be useful for
downstream processing you want to
generalize to new tasks transfer to new
things like we've been talking about so
the and there's this assumption that if
you disentangle the things are going to
be more useful so I agree that those two
aren't always in line right it could be
that something's interpretable isn't
really what's the relevant for the
downstream tasks but they're so far the
synthetic cases are one that you want to
see how well it's doing typically you
want to assume this varies independently
and you can often not the same thing in
our work we're gonna assume two
different work two things they're gonna
be different well first of all we aren't
going to really focus on this aspect of
which is the decoding which is to say
how well can we vary the underlying
dimensions and get something interesting
other than the decoding that's not we're
all interested in some use of this for
downstream tasks and we aren't going to
do it in a purely unsupervised way so
rather than building a lot of
assumptions into the system what we're
going to give it some labels and say
these are some of the dimensions that we
care about in fact they're gonna be the
sensitive attributes
to the decoding so the end coding Maps
the input X to some representation Z and
then you have another system that's
going to predict an input an image let's
say from Z okay so it's like a separate
one more question about the encoding
itself the requirements on Z these are
just desired properties of Z not exactly
requirements right right so what to
prevent me by from just making ZB X
comma a or whatever the whole thing's
and let the adaptation for the task deal
with eliminating the biased features for
each particular task so is that a valid
solution or are you trying to is a
definition preventing that solution so
it doesn't prevent that solution usually
the architecture in a sense prevents
that solution so you won't have but even
and that often is the case where that
isn't necessarily so you lose the I mean
if you have these things these move it
away from that type of representation if
the those dimensions were actually in
the input explicitly represented and
more independent then that could that
could be a potential solution
architecture per minute yes that's it
but it's desired yeah so here maybe this
will help your what I understand what I
meant by this yeah so we have training
time on the left here and test time on
the right so a training time we have X
and a X is going to be this is for a
particular input example we have X as
our non-sensitive
observations and a are sensitive
observations so we partitioned it so a
or all of our senses of a true sense of
attributes we're seeing them at training
time and we're building a an embedding
or a latent description that's also
partitioned into a Z and a beat okay
so B is meant to capture all of the
information about a and and B can also
be useful for aspects of X Z is only
relevant for X so these are the kind of
underlying assumptions in our system
and a test time though we're gonna treat
it differently a test time we're gonna
say we were only going to see X we
aren't going to see the sensitive
attributes and we're gonna predict be
all right which is the information about
a and a prediction about the sensitive
attributes we're gonna predict Z and
then we're going to use Z and B then
we're going to modify B the B Prime
we're gonna say in this particular
setting we're concerned about these
sensitive attributes okay so let's take
what I was talking about before let's
imagine a has race and gender and age
and religion okay and now we're gonna
say in this particular task we want to
you know not discriminate against
whether they say like teenage males so
we're gonna take age and gender out of
it okay so we have B which represents
those four dimensions in some way okay
now we're gonna not allow any
information about gender and age to be
used so B prime is like B with some
censoring you've taken out some
information that in B we're going to
then use beep allow B Prime and Z to be
used to learn some classifier why that
is one particular target ad campaign
that's not discriminating against young
this makes sense a bit confused about
the coordinates yeah so I'm gonna get
into that now right so that could be so
I'm doing it in a very simple way I'm
saying imagine it's one to one right so
there's we learn a representation where
one coordinate of B corresponds the
first one corresponds the first one of a
beat the second course one of the second
one to be etc it doesn't have to be that
simple okay but there is this notion of
identification this is the
disentanglement there has to be
disentanglement that each one of these
only corresponds to one dimension of a
so I'll get into how we're constraining
it but that's what I'm saying this is
what's desired okay and then what we can
do at test time is we can say okay find
me the most relevant coordinates for
whatever the sensitive attributes are
like I said age and gender and have
those be taken out of B
so like you're given the sensitive
conjunction for the task and then you go
through the coordinates of the crime and
zero so the hope is that if there's some
proxy in the data like head-covering for
religion for instance that the presence
of a head covering will somehow not
survive in the sea at all because that
entire all the information about that
proxy will have been absorbed wouldn't
to be and in fact in particular
dimensions of B they're relevant to
whatever that you know whatever the head
covering like if it's a religion or
something right those dimensions of B
that are encoding religion would be the
ones that would representing head cover
so yeah both it's in B and it's specific
within B doesn't is okay good yeah I
know it must be asleep sitting yet right
so this is flexible so what I was
getting at the answer to Cynthia's
question was we're gonna keep the same
encoder the same way of going from X to
Z and B for many different Y's many
different tasks so now a different task
we can go in and say it's no longer
about teenage boys it's about black
females and we're gonna use the same
encoder we're gonna same so we now take
an X we get a Z and a B and now we're
going to take out the dimensions
relevant to race and gender and use that
for whatever the classification
that's right exactly reuse the whole
encoder the Z and B thing for different
sensitive attributes for different tasks
why so it's flexible for different
sensitive attributes and in turn those
can be used for different so that's the
setup so the goal is Z is independent of
every dimension of BJ so that's one goal
up here so there's a separation of
information between what is relevant to
the sense of attributes and what isn't
so that Z is separate from B the
dimensions of B are independent of each
other that's the disentanglement so that
the these things are separate from each
other and furthermore the mutual
information of particular dimensions of
B is strong for particular dimensions of
a okay there's that's this
identification of dimensions that
happens no know XNA are certainly not
independent of each other there's lots
of information about exits na and that's
why be asked to have heads connections
both to X and ay like the head covering
an example X B is going to be head
covering what's it B is gonna represent
something about religion but religion
isn't just a an attribute it's also
something that's going to be in the in
the head covering of something that's in
the image of C
so we're gonna modify so for example if
we wanted to achieve demographic parity
with respect to some particular AI we
would use the regular ZB we take out B
from the BI that corresponds to whatever
that dimension is you say you know one
and then would if we want to have
conjunctions of binary attributes then
we would take out the you know the three
attributes we would take out that
triplet of attributes from B and use
that modified sensitive latent yeah so
that's the Rada it's not necessarily
gonna be satisfied and so that I'm gonna
get to that in the question that in a
minute that's exactly the kinds of
issues that are important
so this is our a learning objective and
there's two important terms to pay
attention to these first and last term
are basically your standard variational
autoencoder terms that you know are two
to relevant for this here the relevant
ones are these two and these are about
this idea of this is the predictiveness
idea which is that each individual
latent dimension BJ it should be
predictive of a single input dimension
age a single sensitive attribute AJ so
that's this one and has some weighting
alpha we want to make that AJ as
predictable as possible from BJ and
remember this is not purely supervised
like the other disentanglement ones
we're actually seeing the A's during
training so these are the dimensions
believe this term is the other one which
is saying that what we were just talking
about that the dimensions of B are
independent of each other that's this
term with a gamma waiting we have this
learning objective as you know with four
different terms in and you got to train
that alright and train up your system on
some data where you get X and ay pairs
and learn some representation like this
and then do this at test time on
different tests okay
yeah the third term is that the
basically saying that the joint of Z and
B should factorize into so Z is
independent of B and the terms of B are
independent of each other
Kayle between the joint and the product
of the marginals for the B's and
so that was both of these terms here
right so he is independent of B and I'm
pointing at this you can't see that and
the peas are independent of each other
yeah sorry why do you want the views to
be independent of each other I mean
that's the this that's if we want to be
able to do this right we want to be able
to say take out the information about
race and gender a city where people of
color are also younger right so that was
the related to the earlier I think so
that is it that is a problem in general
with this entanglement and I'm gonna get
into that okay the correlations in this
is always a challenge
so let me explain some experiments and
these kinds of issues are gonna come up
in the in the experiment so we split the
data into a training set for learning
the encoder and called the audit set for
evaluating it and we have different sets
of sensitive attributes we have note we
have a sensitive attribute set used by
the encoder so that's like the full set
of sensitive attributes and then we're
gonna change them for the different x
training we see the full set of
sensitive attributes and then we audit
it by freezing the end coder like I said
that goes from predict Z and B from X
and now we're gonna predict train up a
classifier to predict some label Y given
the encoder outputs right so now we're
gonna add test time we're gonna audit it
by training up a new classifier that
goes from Z and B prime to Y and we're
going to then specify some subgroup a
based on conjunctions of the sensitive
attributes okay we're gonna do it for
different conjunctions maybe individual
attributes pairs of conjunctions so you
might say well how would we do in this
case in this classifier if we wanted to
not discriminate against young males how
would we do so that would divide the
population into two groups the young
males and the not young males okay how
would we do if we wanted to this not the
scrimp not be biased against black
females so then we have black females
non black females okay so you have this
split of the theta and and then we audit
it for accuracy fairness predictiveness
and disentanglement so what do all those
mean so it basically means so fairness
and accuracy is saying well how well do
we do accuracy how well do we do on some
predicted why when we've taken out some
of those sensitive attributes okay the
fairness is whatever the fairness metric
is I'll just take demographic parity for
now how does that's the typical kind of
thing we have a classifier how how does
that classifier doing in terms of
demographic parity predictiveness is
saying how well does the dimension that
we took out that was meant there were
the dimensions that we took out that was
supposed to predict let's say young
males how well
given just those values can we predict
young males in this test dataset okay so
that's really saying how well who really
learned at a disentangled representation
that can take conjunctions in so now
we're gonna train up with new classifier
that's going to take our B's and take
those dimensions of B that we identified
as being young males and look at them
across the tête the test set and say we
build the classifier on that on that and
how well does that class if I were able
to predict is this individual a young
male or not we can do that for any
conjunction or little attributes
that's the predictiveness spot it then
we've a disentanglement audit which is
the reverse it says given the other
dimensions of B that aren't the ones
that we're saying or identified with
being young male but the ones that are
not young male how well can they predict
young male okay that's what we want
those to be bad at predicting young male
okay so for audits fairness accuracy
predictiveness disentanglement
okay so training up lots of kind of post
hoc classifiers yes you're learning P
and Q ratings over P and Q yeah yep or
given P means your standard given p.m.
you're given it's this is your standard
variational auto encoder right so P is
your goal it's your it's your
distribution of X no standard auto
encoder right so P of X given Z and B
you're trying to match your this is your
log likelihood time that's your
reconstruction term that's the first
term okay so that's this is just like a
maximizing the likelihood of the
observations in this case X given Z and
B so that's yours
you're learning this is you're learning
this is actually going to be used to
learn both the encoder and decoder yeah
yeah so you're training over P you're
training so Q q has this a so I should
so if you forget these terms are the
first and the last term are exactly the
same as your standard VA e right so this
is so imagine this is just P of X given
Z right so you're trying to maximize the
probability of whatever the data is
given your x and dick given Z right and
you have some way of computing that so
yeah okay let's come back to that let me
fit let me finish we can come back like
okay five oh shoot okay all right okay
this is so synthetic data and I'll
present a couple real data quickly so
the synthetic data is a standard thing
used in disentanglement we have things
that vary by shape and position in color
so we have like hearts and squares and
orientation and size so you vary all
these dimensions and then what we're
gonna do is make it a fair
classifications task by predicting the
exposition without discriminating
against scale and shape okay it could be
scale it could be shape it could be
scale and shape or whatever okay so
we're just making this as a synthetic
task where we can then play with things
so this is where we do stuff like we
make it correlated so we make exposition
be correlated with shape and we look at
the effects of that on this whole
objective all right so this is a very
important dimension that I think hasn't
really been done enough in the
disentanglement literature and it's
especially important for fairness where
it could be that the dimensions are
correlate with each other and also them
correlate with what we're interested in
predicting okay and what you see on
these results so let me just say what
these results are this is accuracy
against unfairness so this Delta D P is
when it's zero that means it's as fair
as possible so we want them to be as two
left on the X and up to be more accurate
so the best is up here in this corner
and the and these are all different lot
a sweep of different models train with
different settings of hyper parameters
so different settings of alpha and gamma
those parameters I mentioned before as
well as other settings in the system and
then we just plot out the results as we
check out all these remodels and look
how they do in terms of fairness and
accuracy okay so that's what's being
shown here and this is our model the
flexibly fair one against some of the
baselines which are other
disentanglement methods that we took and
adapted to a fairness setting I can tell
you details about that later
so that was the idea and what you see is
that when scale we can do a perfect job
and that's because scale is not
correlated at all with what we're trying
to predict position so it's easy to
factor it out so this entanglement isn't
hard when these things are really
independent shape is and we're able to
still do a pretty good job much better
than our competitors in terms of making
things fair so pushing it down this way
while maintaining accuracy when we get
into conjunctions of attributes like
scale and shape it's a little harder ok
we were able to get still but we see a
fall-off in accuracy but we you know as
we make things more and more fair so
that's the in the interest of time I'll
just say that about those results
there's an audit it's a remember I said
that was a fairness and accuracy audit
we also do a predictive in this audit so
predictiveness is saying how well do the
individual dimensions let's say predict
scale in shape so this one was actually
done I think on this particular one
where shape is the dimension so we then
take the dimension of our latent code
that's meant to represent shape and we
take that out and use that for example
and build a little classifier to see how
well does it predict shape and you can
see that as we tranq up the weighting on
that term in the loss and these are four
different models with different values
of alpha that for higher values of alpha
the care more about that term it's able
to successfully learn to identify
particular dimension of the latent code
with the sensitive attribute that's high
predictiveness and we also get high
disentanglement which is there are you
know this entanglement is good which
means that the loss is high in other
words the other dimensions aren't able
to predict that
this is just a baseline saying well what
how much information is there actually
in the input about that dimension so I
get one more results and it'll wrap up
so the last result this is we also did
some work on communities in crime that
people have the other folks have used in
this area they where with multiple
sensitive attributes the the and we've
done it with all kinds of things that we
took the percentage that the race
percentage that's black
the per capita average of black
population the percent of those painting
as well these are the sensitive
attributes and are held out label that
we trained up afterwards is on violent
crimes per capita and then we do
different settings of the sensitive
attributes we do all kinds of individual
ones of these as well as conjunctions of
these we say a conjunction would be well
if race or black so that's one setting
of this that's a group that we want to
discriminate against anybody who has
this that is black or has a particular
per capita thing then that is one
setting of the one group and everyone
else is the other group and you want to
look at how well we can just not
discriminate against that particular set
of sensory attributes and we do it for
many different settings of the sensitive
attributes so that's the flexibility
part of it and then we compare and train
lots of models so there's a lot of model
training a lot of work here and the
bottom line is that we're doing a pretty
good job but you know it's you never get
perfect results but we do a pretty good
job of being able to flexibly take the
same end coder and you know use it for
different settings of these sensitive
attributes celeb a we also do these face
data like the face data I showed you
before with forty binary attributes in
this case we chose three of them as the
sensitive attribute settings chubby
eyeglasses and mail these turned out
again to be very correlated with each
other and and with what we were trying
to predict heavy makeup okay and so
there's this is the real world and so
the answer a lot of people's questions
this is that you get these kinds of
correlations that impact the settings in
this in the model so you don't get the
nice curve
we're able to get perfect fairness and
accuracy but you get a trade-off between
the two but you are able to I mean this
is just showing a typical failure case
where we don't do as well as one of our
competitors but most of the cases were
actually doing better so built through
this this flexible thing so bottom line
is we're trying you know it's a ongoing
work we're trying to figure out how to
get downstream classification that can
disentangle information for multiple
sense of attributes that can be then
used flexibly where you specify the
sensitive attributes and reuse the same
encoder and as I said this thorny issue
which is this correlations and the
sensitive attributes and between the
sense of attributes and the labels right
that makes disentanglement that makes
this whole problem of dealing with
multiple sense of attributes quite
challenging now understanding it the
other group fairness definitions and
looking at how well these things
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
certainly the second point the surprise
very very nice hug so you have a lot of
interesting constraints on the model I
read the second point in our dear some
fundamental limitations there's a whole
wall you can't disentangle even a sight
from the Haitian challenges right so
that so I think that's the question that
we're Retel reaction looking at right
now is how well can you do and what
kinds of things can you do when you have
these correlations it's not so for
example it could be that you can pull
out all the information about one of the
sensitive attributes it's very
correlated with this other sense of
attribute you're gonna necessarily take
out information about that right so that
is the kind of thing so you have these
inherent limitations on how well you can
extract or remove information about one
without affecting the others and you
know so we're looking at trying to
develop methods that are do a better job
of separating things easier than the
presence of correlation that push up
against the limits but there's inherent
limits so there's no way we can do
better than that so I think that there's
an interesting from a theoretical point
of view and also from an empirical point
of view
[Music]
[Applause]